we're talking about sandoval and again
the stuff is excellent it's a stuff but
it's one thing to have a stuff then
corral it and learn what to do with it
that's exactly what has gone on he's
taken that a stuff gooby and translate
it into an effective starting pitch
and he lost him
[Applause]
and he earned the walk and the runner
will move to third so with two outs
that's certainly not what you were
looking for mount castle for just the
17th time this year walks he's been
difficult to walk
here's the 3-2
it's a fast ball 96 overthrew it
arm never was able to catch up with his
body so this is not what we have seen of
late but it's a three walk first inning
for sandoval
so here is the
left-handed hitting
d.j stewart
sandoval against stewart with the bases
loaded
got him
slider firm over the outside corner oh
baby did he make his own mess
but in the end he cleaned it up he needs
to hydrate
fourth start for eshelman this season
and fletcher greets him quickly with a
ground ball through the left side
a base hit for david fletcher who's
going to try to make a two and he will
david fletcher hot puts it out of the
box
and a lead off double his 14th double of
the season
so joe madden juggled the lineup today
and he moved jared walsh up to hit
behind shohei ohtani let's see if they
attack him
ohtani goes down on a very slow breaking
ball he really backed off of that one so
jared walsh is the batter he's hitting
284 20 homers 60 runs batted in
rocket shot toward the corner it goes oh
it's just another day and it's just
another jared walsh extra base hit at
rbi
love the fact
he got the green light
knows the strike zone
knows those assortment of secondary
pitches and still be quick enough on a
fastball if he throws it and he lines it
in the corner for an rbi double
left field oh the goose is loose again
it's two to nothing
and the goose didn't exactly square that
up but he put it in play no two pitch
usually the change up
he went with the fastball it's on the
ground it may be very rewarding look at
those two work
together oh
baby
and shohei ohtani will be the next
batter one gone
dude
center field let's watch it go wow
wow
that back flip that went 459
feet shohei ohtani 31 home runs tying
kedeki matsui's all-time home run mark
for a japanese-born hitter in the major
leagues 31 home runs xiaohe ohtani
459 center field and he got that pitch
didn't move around kept the feet still
and that great backflip by the way he
waited going down the line there with
that backflip
number 31. shohei
[Applause]
anthony rendon sends that one toward the
corner will render it to her he will
a home run for anthony rendon
six of the year
i'm talking about someone needed to show
that power just to get that swing
together he's been playing outstanding
defense but he hooks that one over the
short wall and left field for anthony
rindo sixth home run two home runs in
the inning for the halos now up for the
nothing that was a pitch upstairs to
ryan mount castle three and two is the
count
we'll do things like that and that's a
strikeout down he goes
up
he's ready and the next delivery in
there says swinging a miss a slider gets
stuart struck him out for the second
time counts full as sandoval delivers
and that is a called third strike on a
change up got him looking
and sandoval strikes out the side in the
inning to the left-hander zach lowther
making his fourth appearance he does
have one start so far era elevated zach
will be thrust into the midst of shohei
ohtani
got him swinging with a curveball louder
strikes out otoni here is jared walsh
and strike three now goes walsh
[Applause]
lazy is waiting on deck next pitch this
is lifted high and hit pretty well under
right field but it's hanging up and
making the catch on that one is haze
just a few feet from the rim of the
track the inning is over so anthony
rendon left today's game with left
hamstring tightness randhifa with third
base now ureas into left field and
ramona rios will get the orioles on the
board
austin hayes around to score trey
mancini to third and ramone takes second
and rbi double for ramon
runners now on second and third with
that double
dj stewart a first pitch attack and
stuart will bring in two
all the way to the wall for dj to score
trey and ramone it's a two-run double
it's a three-run third and the o's are
right back within a run
now cedric mullins after being announced
as a first-time all-star will pinch it
for austin wins
mullen's a little fister
this one will drop in for a base hit
the 100th hit of cedric mullins 2021
season
is his first officially as an all-star a
pitch hit single to tie the game in the
six
kurt suzuki who's popped out to first
and is also grounded out to shortstop
suzuki hits a breaking ball out to left
field mckenna makes a great catch
oh ryan mckenna highway robbery at the
warning track watch the jump straight
away left field cross over step moving
and watch lays out at the last second
and an outstanding play and there is
cedric mullins to pick him up and i'm
telling you you won't see a better play
than that today
here is cedric mullins better be right
with this hitter puts it in the air
right field it is deep this one's headed
for the wall and this ball is
gone cedric mullins clears the wall in
right field and the all-star
makes it 5-4 orioles in the ninth inning
mullins the newly minted all-star puts
the orioles on top of the night the
angels load the bases with nobody out a
hit here could win it
fights that one off drives it toward
right center field mullins chases it's
down
up against the wall one laguardis walks
them off it's an angel sweep what a shot
other way walk off